homme jean paul gaultier bah écoutez
franchement est ce assez d'accord je
comprends mais que vous en vendez
énormément c'est magnifique mais est ce
que vous croyez qu'on est pas ridicule
après un certain âge absolument perd 18
ans et demi je veux dire non je crois
que si vous voulez il n'y a pas de
notion d'âge dans la mode
je crois qu'en fin de compte c'est
suivant si l'on se sent bien dans sa
peau c'est surtout ça en fin de compte
tire qu'une femme peut s'habiller à 60
ans comme ça j'en vois très bien où il y
en a d'autres avaient un taux qui jamais
notre emporté ça c'est simplement la
question d'avoir envie de vouloir
s'amuser c'est la motion justement comme
le disait si bien à vicky de d'amusement
et aussi un petit peu comme des rêves
d'enfants vouloir un jour être un peu
une héroïne vouloir jouer vouloir se
déguiser le mardi gras en fin de compte
le mardi gras c'est gai et on en a
besoin dans la vie de tous les jours et
c'est exactement ce que je dis on va me
revoir alors à la classique que vous
faites parce que tous les deux vicky com
com vous jean paul gaultier mais qui
tienne vous avez une formation
deux dessins hyper classique vous êtes
capable de faire un petit tailleur
prince de galles et puis à difficultés
qui pouvaient pas du tout d'accord je
suis pas capable de faire un tailleur
dites moi j'ai d'ailleurs prince de
galles je dois dire si moi je trouve si
vous voulez je voudrais préciser quand
même c'est que ça je suis pas là pour
vous l'eau est si ça peut être si si si
ça peut être avec la jupe mais s'il ya
c'est que j'essaierai de trouver un
mélange c'est à dire sur une chemise
soit quelque chose un accessoire qui à
la limite pour qu'ils n'aimera pas du
tout avec cookie donnant une autre
allure et adamaï carbis d'ailleurs deux
modèles qu'on va nous montrer dans un
instant à l'écran et je crois qu'il faut
faire ça un jour dans sa vie ce vous qui
n'avez jamais cherché à être transformés
voilà ce que j'appelle assez classique
masculin féminin donc à droite et
c'était sur la gauche là une robe avec
des découpes un petit peu comme les
jeans mais sexy c'est à dire avec les
épaules nues la taille étranglée et le
gilet masculin mais sexy aussi parce que
porter à même la peau dites moi tous les
deux donc vie qui tienne jean paul
gaultier est ce que vraiment il faut des
excès d outrance pour faire prendre
conscience aux gens que la vie peut être
un film en technicolor
l excès ça veut dire certaines personnes
qui vont faire plus que les autres par
exemple oui il ya des personnages qui
s'y promènent dans la rue on se regarde
ils ont l'air déguisée en fait ils sont
peut-être très très heureux il lance
je suis arrivé en france j'ai porter des
minijupes dans les années 60
j'ai marché dans nos rues et tout le
monde a des cannibales carnival et puis
six mois plus tard tout le monde portait
mon mini jupe
il ya toujours une ou deux personnes qui
commencent l'affolement et après deux
ans plus tard c'est parce que c'est même
plus fort c'est démodé il n'a pas de
raison d'un nomade 61.2 stioui le mode
n'est pas sérieux à la mode n'est pas
sérieux dégâts aux cultures qui se prend
trop au sérieux et le prévoit
je crois ne correspond plus du tout
aujourd'hui faut bien le dire
ah oui à la haute couture en fait c'est
la locomotive de ce que vous faites dans
vos recherches qui s'inspire quand même
un petit peu je dirais du passé excusez
moi de vous dire oui mais c'est aussi du
cinéma c'est le cinéma chez vous donc je
crois qu'on est empreint enfin on est
une génération en plus enfin je sais pas
de la bande dessinée du cinéma ont été
marqués par des images donc c'est
évident que ça se reflète un peu dans
tout ce qu'on fait moi je sais que par
exemple la robe sexy qu'on a vu
justement avec les épaules nues ont
balisé pour le nu c'est quoi pour moi
c'est quand j'étais petit j'avais vu
sissi impératrice
on s'était les épaules nues j'ai trouvé
sa superbe et on leur transe craie
aujourd'hui mais fait dans une matière
qui n'a rien à voir comment le chasse au
trésor va le jeu la tenue que je portais
c'était le cas c'est parce que vous
aviez le du pain la coiffure qu'elle est
parfaitement avec je veux dire quand on
veut donner une image forte
mais vous pouvez le porter sans le
bustier ce qui changeait tout le bustier
justement d'opérette sa douce agréé
autre chose bon et vicky on a
l'impression que ces robes sont été
peuvent être portés par esther williams
marilyn monroe aussi on rêve tout aussi
bien porté par évelyne trash à la fin je
me suis beaucoup amusé mais j'ai eu
comme un peu peur je vis au fond
peut-être que je suis passé à côté de ma
vie et peut-être beaucoup de femmes se
sont dit la même chose
vous êtes les engagerait tout en un jour
profiter de ces de ces vacances de mardi
gras de la mi carême pour aller
s'acheter une tenue complètement de vols
pas chers plus au début tu as parlé de
la mort une certaine rage une femme du
noyau tonnage de matières et je me
souviens quand j'avais 18 ans comment
une femme d'un certain âge étaient
trente ans avait 30 ans 30 50 et
maintenant j'ai 35 ans et je trouve que
la famille
j'aurai 70 ans je trouve que l'idée dans
notre esprit
le jonas est toujours là où on est ici
on est jeune on a toujours l'idée qu'on
est jeune et on devait rester jeunes
pourraient bien dans nos projets et vous
connaissez un peu vos clients oui mais
justement sont très diverses c'est à
dire qu'il peut y avoir aussi bien les
femmes dites classiques qui
interpréteront les vêtements d'une autre
façon que les autres qui sont plus
excentrique mais en général je voulais y
a pas le critère d'âge patrie terre non
plus deux silhouettes je veux dire je
n'ai dès tout petit j'en ai les plus
grandes et en fin de compte c'est le
tout d'aider mais comporte c'est surtout
sa joie en tout cas moi j'ai aimé jouer
avec vous merci vie qui tiennent merci
jean paul gaultier et merci à bacha qui
a dû vraiment quand même qui a fait un
gros effort pour me convaincre de
changer de style va je vais réussir
merci beaucoup c'est